[Música]
[Aplausos]
agora voltar todos
isso é muito pior do que o filme estava
a dizer é importante
espero que que o som e tentamos algo
daqui nos próximos nos próximos minutos
nós vivemos num mundo em que influencia
digital é enorme
homens e máquinas estão literalmente
ligados quase em permanência através da
questão em questões atuais efetivamente
se pensarmos um pouco a imagem digital é
um dos principais meios de ligação é
grande questão que se coloca é é será
que nós podemos confiar efetivamente a
imagem digital que não chegam aos nossos
olhos todos os dias
bom esse é um desafio que eu gostaria de
partilhar convosco durante os próximos
minutos
efetivamente não foi sempre assim a
fotografia surgiu com base em duas
grandes invenções
a primeira quebra da procura ea segunda
o encontrar de materiais que são
sensíveis aos a câmera obscura com o
próprio nome indica não é mais do que
uma caixa sem luz onde existe apenas um
pequeno orifício dependendo das
dimensões do edifício e do tamanho da
caixa ou servas que há uma formação de
uma imagem nítida naquilo que é presa
oposta orifício
este foi o princípio da fotografia e da
forma como ela apareceu originalmente
isso não era usado para o registo
fotográfico começou por ser usado em
astronomia para avaliar os astros do sol
etc mas mais tarde através do registo
por pintura ou por desempenho e cresça
foi a primeira forma de registar o mundo
como nós o conhecemos
mais tarde o aparecimento então do
material químico que permite ser
sensível à luz é possível obter então
fotografia de forma automática a imagem
que está à nossa esquerda data de 1820
tudo indica e foi a primeira fotografia
de que há registo que sobreviveu o tempo
até aos 2 imagem à nossa direita
vinte anos depois cresceu foi a primeira
fotografia com pessoas é rua está à
nossa frente estava
tudo indica com pessoas também mas elas
não ficaram gravadas devido ao longo
tempo de exposição e portanto sobraram
duas pessoas que estão no canto inferior
esquerdo da imagem
porque efetivamente elas estavam paradas
durante todo esse tempo de exposição
anos mais tarde já no século 20 se deus
é grande em função da fotografia o
crescimento do filme fotográfico nós
ainda hoje o conhecemos pelo menos
alguns de nós é evolução normal da
tecnologia da altura permite começar a
ter algumas câmeras portáteis próximo
transportáveis e que nos permitirão
passar a registar um mundo forma muito
mais fácil
este filme passou também a permitir o
registro de imagem na coxa
com o passar do tempo a descoberta do
transe história grande revolução da
eletrônica e automaticamente também
sofreu na fotografia
passámos a ter aquilo que nós chamamos
os sensores digitais vulgarmente
chamados e mostras e dependendo da
tecnologia ea partir desse momento
passamos até a fotografia disponível no
computador do resultado desde sensor é
na prática um ficheiro digital pode ser
importado para um qualquer computador
telemóvel e pode ser manipulado pode ser
impresso pode ser simplesmente mostrá lo
é este sensor não faz mais do que captar
e medir a luz que atravessa lente o
mesmo princípio que eu mostrei a pouco
na câmera obscura passado estamos todos
a tecnologia continua a usufruir daquilo
que foi o princípio como tudo começou
everson eletrônica tudo passou a ser
mais pequeno com microeletrônica a
evolução tecnológica de modo geral e
hoje em dia temos câmeras digitais em
quase todo o avaí
temos nosso mar fome temos a câmera
digital com uma panóplia de modelos à
disposição muitas marcas muitas mães
características diferentes mas também
passamos a ter a utilização da imagem
digital para outros fins
robótica ea vigilância verificação de
identidade e toda uma série de
aplicações nós usamos quase sem saber
mas o desafio de trazer aqui hoje tem a
ver também com pensar na imagem não só
como forma de gravarmos o nosso dia a
dia mas acima de tudo como forma de
comunicação efetivamente imagem é um
poderoso meio de comunicação eu diria
talvez um dos mais importantes nos dias
milhões pessoas não dizer biliões de
pessoas por todo o mundo utilizam as
redes sociais para comunicar não só
entre pessoas mas também entre pessoas e
toda a comunidade a circundantes temos
também as empresas em minha parte das
entidades é usar as redes sociais como
meio principal de comunicação
bom os números são efetivamente
impressionantes desde que nós entramos
aqui nesta sala já foram publicados
milhões de imagens nas redes sociais
desde o início do dia
já contamos com 74 milhões de
fotografias só numa das redes sociais
está grandes se olharmos para os números
desde o início do ano são ainda mais
impressionantes estamos a falar de 10
biliões de fotografias tornadas públicas
é verdade que o alcance das fotos não é
todo igual tendo muito aquilo que são as
nossas subscrições aquilo que são as
nossas redes de contatos
de qualquer forma isso tem um impacto
brutal na que o que a sociedade digital
dos dois mas da esposa agora um desafio
à parte voz deve conhecer esta foto e o
desafio que eu gostaria é tensa em um
segundo se o conteúdo desta mensagem
fotografia mais triste por conde
festivamente a finalidade efectiva mente
é a fotografia real existia um ser
humano junto àquela placa num
determinado país só que a mensagem que
queria transportar não era efetivo entre
ao povo um jornal da manhã que quis
perceber qual é o impacto de uma notícia
falsa na internet até onde é que
conseguia chegar com essa mensagem
o resultado foi surpreendente esta
mensagem estou em poucos minutos as
melhores pessoas e conta efetivamente
uma mensagem é que não é verdadeira não
era gravo não causou grande transtorno
ninguém ao contrário de muitas outras
situações mais sérias por esse mundo
fora
esta imagem foi usada para hurghada
mente indicar o informar as pessoas de
que tenha havido assassinatos de
militantes de um partido na ilha hora
precisou se mais tarde que esta cirurgia
não tenha sido mais do que um fluxo
resultado e um atentado suicida que o
mesmo país
poderíamos continuar com os exemplos
presidente francês no almoço tranquilo
alguns nas montanhas receber uma bela
garrafa de vinho
é o contexto esta imagem foi usado muito
recentemente nas redes sociais
num dos muitos dias sem que tenha havido
manifestações em frança dos 40 graus
mais do que isso a mensagem do papa até
isto é dizer que esta época rafting e
gustavo vários milhares de euros
ora tudo isto incentiva ainda mais
violência mas acima de tudo fruto de
informação que não era de todo bordado
nem a fotografia e se tirar um dia de
manifestações nem aquela garrafa se
provou ter gostado nada parecido com o
que eu os exames continuam não é difícil
encontrar o simplesmente online tomada
de posse do presidente dos estados
unidos
imagem à nossa esquerda imagem real foi
aquela que efetivamente foi adquirida
com a câmera usada a imagem da direita
foi aquela foi publicada nas redes
oficiais do governo mostra apenas uma
parte daquilo que era a informação real
efetivamente também nós todos na verdade
científica da área junto com as empresas
tecnológicas que suportam todas as redes
sociais temos estado a trabalhar na
tentativa de encontrar algoritmos
software a e forma de identificar aquilo
que a mensagem verdadeira mensagem é
falsa o mesmo conteúdo que é divulgado
temos também todos a noção de mesmo
tecnológicamente ainda estamos muito
longe de ter uma solução funciona em
todas as circunstâncias
há também o segundo problema tem a ver
com as questões da legislação e vivemos
numa sociedade livre e portanto ainda há
muita questão em termos de
regulamentação e legislação que é
preciso atacar mas deixou também um
outro desafio é num posto twitter
tratamento normal como muitos outros
a questão que se coloca é será que esta
imagem é mesmo verdadeira é tudo indica
que o cheias no estado do texas
mas eu tinha até o sítio essa é a
pergunta que fica é a resposta se nós
virmos 2 é mais tarde com cuidado a
resposta é não efetivamente ou cheias ou
muita água nos canais que os estados
unidos têm por hábito criar junto às
cidades para resolver as questões das
cheias mas não não estava lá ninguém
daqui os bichinhos a passear foi
realmente a mistura a combinação de uma
imagem capturada em alto mar
isso é possível porque houve uma
evolução tecnológica que nos permite
hoje em dia como já vimos adquirir
imagem digital mas acima de tudo permite
daí modificá-la e de forma extremamente
fácil os exemplos do monte este é apenas
mais um efetivamente esta perturbação
nunca existiu e doutor nota mais do que
combinação de duas imagens tiradas em
conta esse comportamento em frente mas a
tecnologia foi muito mais longe mais um
desafio no meio dos vários jogos deixará
ir seis fotografias seus rostos
acham que algum destes rosto é real
olhem com atenção as respostas calhar
agora depois desta conversa que ele é
óbvia não não só uma destas cargas
existe na realidade é isto estas imagens
foram obtidas por um computador foram
geradas automaticamente fruto do
trabalho de investigação dos vários anos
de uma empresa tecnológica desta área
estas como estas imagens são geradas por
computador é fruto de modelos foram
criados conal e milhões de imagens de
rostos humanos dos quais 63 das
propriedades e depois que combinadas
conseguem produzir imagens novas é esta
aplicação não só serve para gerar a
imagem com rostos mas pode ser usada
para tirar objetos para todos os tipos
de imagem digital a mesma tecnologia que
nós usamos para é trabalhar para extrair
informação útil da mesma m depois mais
tarde também terá capacidade de gerar
automaticamente informação que não
existe isso pode efetivamente ser um
problema e é isso que nos tem preocupado
a comunidade científica esta dualidade
entre usar a tecnologia para o bem do
ser humano e usar a tecnologia para fins
que nós não desejamos de todo bom
este software é apenas um exemplo de
muitas coisas que nós conseguimos fazer
com imagem eu considere impressionantes
poder gerar rostos humanos simplesmente
alterando alguns parâmetros computadores
tanto foi aqui é que nós estamos neste
momento do ponto de vista daquilo que é
a capacidade de aprendizagem das
máquinas não está velho
nós temos trabalhado também ao longo dos
últimos anos no tratamento de imagem
digital
temos um longo histórico daquilo que é a
robótica que usa nos dias 2 como
principal sensor de imagem mas também no
que toca o tema que nos traz aqui hoje
que é perceber se uma imagem foi ou não
foi alterada
estamos neste momento a trabalhar em
novos algoritmos software que permite
olhando avaliando construir uma imagem
precisa ver se ela foi ou não modificada
após a sua aquisição
estamos também a trabalhar em algoritmos
que permitem extrair dados de uma imagem
imagem contém a informação visual e nós
tentamos extrair dessa informação visual
palavra-chave conteúdo seja usando para
isso temos de escrever chamamos
normalmente isso metadados e há também
uma longa experiência no nosso grupo
trabalho naquilo que nós chamamos de
extração de informação útil de texto
principalmente complicação na área da
medicina mas que pode ser usado para
outros fins dependendo do contexto
combinando as três fontes de informação
estamos neste momento a trabalhar em
algoritmos de aprendizagem máquinas para
tentar perceber se efetivamente uma
mensagem composta por texto e por imagem
tem ou não tem algum conteúdo possa ser
eventualmente delicioso
você recentemente uma imagem perfeita
bem tranquila sem qualquer desafio da
humanidade bom 10 com estas inquietações
do mundo digital em que vivemos apenas
com dois desafios sejam críticos com a
mensagem que não chega às redes sociais
que chegou a voz que mais gostam e móvel
tenham cuidado com a informação digital
partilham esta facilidade estamos todos
ligados temos acesso a câmeras digitais
por vezes não nos deixa a pensar naquilo
que devemos ou não tivemos efectivamente
partilhar antes sejam cuidadosos tenta e
não como contribuir para que o que é
efetivamente o lixo digital que nós
estamos a deixar hoje em dia
obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]